[Music]
the day I was going to sign my papers to
start working there were 3,000 inmates
out there working iron and I was like
what did I get myself into you
my name is Carmen Sharon I'm the career
technical and educator for cosmetology
at Baltic state prisons women when I
tell people that I work teaching
cosmetology and a men's president a lot
of people are shocked buyers are
surprised they didn't even think that it
was available the program takes
approximately two years and they have to
have 1,600 hours completed in order to
take the State Board of cram there is a
waiting list to get into this class and
in order to get into this class an
inmate has to meet certain behavioral at
educational on standards well you come
into my classroom you're going to treat
each other with respect and common
courtesy and there's no boundaries in
here which is going to relax your facial
muscles and improve your blood flow
throughout your face my name is Juan
Ruiz wellö I'm here at Valley State
Prison in Chowchilla California my
favorite part of the class is the skin
care part of it which includes like the
face shows eyebrows and makeup I like to
to see my clients relax and get
comfortable with me with it's real
personal and being in prison they teach
you not to touch each other not to touch
staff it goes against the norm of what
people see about prison on TV you know
ex-gang members come in with tattoos on
their face all over their body is not
something that you see out there working
in a beauty salon just putting a line on
a distance
presentation I do treat them as you
would me and I'm not here to punish them
I'm just share to show them a skill that
I have and it happens to be in a
business I have more empathy for people
now because of doing this type of work
when they get their license it's like
I've got in mind for the first time all
over again it's very rewarding in Italia
in mr. a her husband petting a dog to a
career Candela she also have a company
she brew travel expenses which on de
Levante Capello chivalry actually in
those ligaments drop the reins of you
fall said you don't have it you voltage
in the pelvic area
the table giving us a lot Sagarika
pretty much irrelevant question about
importante we Shamu Lathika barbarous
Cola la crema Barbary remoulade Oh
edible berry ah so additional comme un
Contadina cerebellar service in Sarto
kunos de las navas una volta chief
achieve only Capelli Krishnamurthy
importante fheo epal Canela cuando
villanova any the nor any ratio general
taunted reversals tanto brandy have
touch with Bobby Ray
Munna Volta Yaiba Baroness or demote
importante
Ola more to divest Oh is Bobby la mala
Vista Pew
a mission to modo de vaisseau no-foam
Sta
we're on fire burning table when a
well-directed a blobby we are which is
appealing no fastly Allah Ramallah you
get your hair done you can't be touched
you're just you're on point for at least
48 hours the queer community needs a
safe space to get haircuts and that's
partly reason why I'm here my name is
des Marshall I'm a barber I work in
Brooklyn New York the barbershop I work
at is called the gamesman it's kind of
an institution here in downtown Brooklyn
the owner Frank has been here for over
50 years the clientele has been a lot of
men who working in the neighborhood a
lot of lawyers a lot of judges other
types of businessmen I kind of throw a
wrench into all of that I mix it up a
little bit my clientele is mostly clear
transgender not conforming folks of
color not folks of color for the most
part my clientele is the LGBTQ community
I think with barbershops it's difficult
as a woman to walk in the can sometimes
to feel like a boys club it's nice to
feel like you can let your hair down or
get it off
I think I'm building a bridge in
different ways can you BFI 3:30 I got
your four queer folks to trans folks are
gender non-conforming fold hair is very
important you keep it really crisp or
more round interaction or you need a
barber that you feel comfortable to talk
to about how you want to look what's
that vision that you have someone who
can execute it but also do it in a way
that they're not going to be judging you
throughout the whole process
like that time keep it up I get to spend
my day with other queer folks in a space
that you know twenty years ago we
probably come into the walk
walked into you know I'm part of that
story now my clients are a part of
Esther and I were part of a history of
this place we're part of its legacy yes
it's really cool
I would call names such as monster
two-faced and Scarface hey guys welcome
back to my channel
poster in my videos made me realize that
this is my mission I won't take it back
this is absolutely the reason why it
happened - hey guys welcome back to my
channel if you knew my name is Sheila
black today we are going to be doing
makeup
my name is Shalom and I'm with YouTube
videos I teach people how to do makeup
and Oprah encouraged them to love them
for who they are without the makeup I
was burned by a cooking oil when I was -
goal and my mother's wrestling back in
Nigeria I remember waking up to
screaming and - enough my skin and
rubbing off my face
it was really terrible for me
[Music]
at our suicide I was in the mural just
looking at myself like why don't people
just like me
I know that my MOT loved me and she
would be really I'm glad to lose a child
you know because she felt like she
refused on one
[Music]
grab pretty I started to feel better
about myself when I saw other people
that were burned too and I wanted to
help people like me my solution was
trying to cover up my scars so I thought
why not I'll make up this is going to be
talked through step by step cover up
scar in my face when are your comments
for my deals telling me that I helped
them it makes me remember why I'm doing
this I like to focus positivity on my
videos you know it's not just putting on
the makeup but having a message that
comes with it that makeup isn't just
what I love to do you know I want to
make you feel good even when you don't
have to make applause I'm just happy
because I found myself I learned to
accept my scars and I also just love me
for who I am
you
[Music]